[Music]
liberation of Paris what a day that one
France spent four terrible years under
the control of Nazi Germany liberation
and then the end of the war brought
relief and sprawling crowds onto the
streets of Paris and beyond today the
noisy euphoria of victory replaced by
the quiet of a lockdown Paris
curiously peaceful
original plans canceled instead it fell
to president Makram first to recognize
his wartime predecessor Schultz de
Gaulle and then to lay a wreath at the
Tomb of the Unknown Soldier
beneath the Arc de Triomphe he liked his
nation taking a moment to reflect there
were a handful of dignitaries present
the Prime Minister and two previous
presidents but this was very subdued all
done within an hour this was a solemn
reflective event but it was also a brief
one quite a contrast to the
commemoration that had been planned
today there was no fly past no parade no
huge crowds and we didn't have a lineup
of veterans but across France there are
those who remember the war and the
horrors of Nazi occupation in the
suburbs of northern Paris we meet Jean
she joined the French Resistance in its
earliest days and spent the war trying
to undermine Nazi control she's now
hundred and one years old and remembers
everything I only call you Jacques what
the skin who's there Sudi skin jose de
sica Delta be my take on your I suppose
I committed if you see friends were
betrayed
arrested and sometimes killed too your
semi-pro Katia hockey practice you know
I'm sorry ba-gawk-oh machinist your
nails have a posse soir naruto song :
there are all of you to be nice a result
unless I know you told me this very day
he felt that it cost me feet to hold mmm
giggles them diggers
Germany to mark the end of the war today
accepting responsibility for millions of
deaths saying the legacy of Nazism still
breaks the nation's heart modern Europe
was shaped by this war its battles
atrocities its end and its aftermath a
conflict that still reverberates a
lifetime later Adam Parsons Sky News
Paris